sziasztok a következő vendégem gábor
attila egy pubg gamer 19 éves és
pincérként dolgozik emellett a pubg
játékon két-három órát játszik naponta
egy nagyon tehetséges játékos megyei
bajnok volt és az ország legjobbjai
közés számíthatóak az ő teljesítménye
világszinten is megállja a helyét
tekintettel arra hogy ez a gamer világ
elég távol áll tőlem én mint 37 éves
három gyermekes családapa alig
foglalkozok ezzel a világgal egy
teljesen új számomra ismeretlen
territóriumon találtam magam attilát
kérdeztem mindenféléről a játékról a
játékon belüli stratégiákról élményekről
is teljesen megdöbbentő volt számomra
hogy a benne levő stratégiák a
sunce háború művészete stratégiáival
gyakorlatilag egy az egybe talál
számomra egy érdekes és tartalmas
beszélgetés volt tartsatok velünk és
ismerjétek meg egy gamer világnak a
rejtélyeit
szervusz attila üdvözöllek a műsorunkba
egy nagyon izgalmas beszélgetés előtt
fogunk állni mert te kerestél meg
ezelőtt vag három hónappal talán hát káb
körülbelül három hónappal ezelőtt hogy a
pubg világában te egy egy tapasztalt
valaki vagy és egy bajnok vagy úgymond
őszintén szólva nekem fogalmam se volt
mi ez a pubg tehát én most 37 éves
vagyok és te 19 éves igen és és rá
kellett jönnöm hogy
alázatosan meg kell tanulnom hogy mi az
a pubg meg kell tanulnom hogy milyen a a
mostani generációnak a gaming világa
ezekről fogunk beszélgetni hogyha isten
hozott a műsorunkba attila köszönöm
meghívást nagyon szívesen kezdjük egy
egyszerűbb bemelegítő kérdésre te most
mint pincér dolgozol ugye mióta dolgozol
pincérként tehát elvégezted a sulit már
suliközben is dolgozgattál suliközben is
igen amit meséltél nekem az az hogy
emellett intenzíven neki fogtál játszani
ezen a pubg-n ez a pubg ez a player
unknown battlegroundnak a rövidítése és
ez egy ilyen battle royale játék ami ami
egy kicsit mesélnél erről a játékról
hogy milyen típusú játék hogyan képzelj
el az átlag hallgató ezt a játékot aki
még nem is hallott róla hát ez a játék
úgy működik hogy multiplayerrel is meg
mindenféle tehát több mód van benne ez
úgy működik hogy player van egy klasszik
meccsbe amelyek repülőből zuhannak ki
egy térképre esnek azt a helyet hogy
hova ugranak azt ők válasszák ki saját
maguk aztán miután leérkeznek
lelandolnak fegyvereket lootokat
kiegészítőket keresnek van egy
biztonságos zóna
amibe benne kell lenni mivel ha kívül
vagy akkor folyamatosan sebző így van
sebzőt és az a lényeg hogy te legyél az
utolsó túlélő így nyered meg a meccset
tehát gyakorlatilag van egy folyamat
osan csökkenő pálya egymás ellen játszik
100 játékos ennek több üzemmódja is van
ugye ahogy utána olvastam az egyik az
hogy mindenki mindenki ellen a másik az
hogy párban tehát duóztok és van a a
amit a leggyakrabban játszatok az a
amikor négyen vagytok egy csapatban
igen igen és mi mióta játszod ezt a
játékot hát olyan
2018-219 óta mikor bejött a covid akkor
hagytam ab a focit és átvette a helyét a
pubg ühüm hát ezt az egészet úgy kezdtem
hogy egyszer a sulibba de focit online
játszottad vagy pedig nem nem hanem a
valóá baráimmal így van igen igen és
azóta annyira elszűgült hogy egyáltalán
már nem focizunk ühüm ühüm és így
2018-19 óta átvette a pubg hát a sulian
hallottam róla egy-két szót és akkor
letöltöttem én is másnap és úgy kezdtünk
játszani barátaimmal egyre intenzívebben
hm és így jöttünk vele igen hát hogy a
hallgatóknak is mondom mert én is meg
kellett tanuljom azt hogy a pubg most az
egyik legnagyobb játék ebbe a
kategóriába sok millió ember játssza és
itt romániában is nagyon sok 1000
játékos játssza komoly klánok vannak ha
jól értettem itt román romániában is de
a a az amerikaiak az oroszok az indiaiak
nagyon
nagyon potens csapatokkal rendelkeznek
kis klánokkal
itt románia hol áll világszinten hát
szerintem a top 10-ben benne van a top
10-ben a top 10-ben benne van szóval
szerintem igen szóval egy nagyon
prominens helyen is van románia és amit
gyakorlatilag még érdemes tudni hogy ezt
főként mobilon játsszák a emiatt is
terjedt el például indiában mert nagyon
ahhoz képest a hardver igénye tehát a
telefon igénye nem magas tehát hogy a
belépési küszöb az egy egy alacsonyabb
teljesítményű telef on is
elérhető de viszont ahhoz hogy gondolom
hogy versenyszinten űzze valaki oda
azért egy ütősebb telefont kell igen
azért szükséges igen neked milyen
telefonod van hát most jelenleg iphone
13 pro maxon játszok ühüm de eddig
iphone 11-en játszottam az azon 60 fps
van ezen illetve 120 és ha jól értettem
akkor a ezekből bajnokságokat is
szerveznek és és a bajnokságun tehát
amikor a versenyre kerül a sor akkor
csak mobil telefonal lehet belépni hát
általában igen telefonos versenyeket
szerveznek mivel ez egy telefonos játék
de van külön ipadeseknek ühüm illetve
pc-seknek tehát akkor külön ipaden is
azoknak külön kategóriában játszák csak
az igen csak az nem annyira nem annyira
intenzíven szervezik az olyanokat ühüm
mi miért gondolod hogy a mobil az az
népszerűbb ipaden nem élvezetesebb
játszani nagyob k hát élvezetesebb csak
könnyebb azon csak könnyebb érted de van
pc-n is ha jól értettemb persze persze
és xboxon és hát én az xboxról nem
hallottam pc-n könnyebb játszani hát
előnyösebb de nehezebb hozzászokni
nehezebb
hozzászokni elképesztő volt számomra
hogy egy shtter játékot lehet játszani
mobilon tehát hogy hogy lehet célozni és
át megkértem hogy küldj át egy pár
videót ezzel kapcsol egyszerűen
eszméletlenl hogy milyen sebességgel
játsszák nagyon izgalmas volt nézni hogy
ez ez a tempó ez a ez ez ez a
felpörgetett sebesség ez ez hihetetlen
tényleg hogy hogy hogy mit ki lehet
hozni egy touch sccreenes képernyőből
2018-ban kezdted el játszani mennyit
játszol naponta
hát naponta most így ahogy dolgozok egy
két-három órát most egy két-három órát a
munkád mellett igen ez eszméletlen és a
a a a amikor nem dolgoztál hát akkor
több időm volt ilyen 5-6 órát 7é órát is
rászántam ühüm átlagban tehát ez egy
átlagosátag így van átlagban ez egy é
suli mellett akkor
így van amúgy a jegyeid milyenek voltak
elég jók voltak elég jók voltak igen
tehát akkor nem nem az volt hogy a munkó
vagyis a bocsánat a tanulásrólvásárra
ment a a játék a szüleid mit szóltak
ehhezá hogy hogy neki fogtál játszani és
hat-hét órát ezzel töltesz hát őket
igazából csak akkor zavartam amikor
éjjel igazából túlzásba vittem néha ühüm
hangoskodtam addig nem nagyon az mit
jelent hogy hangoskodsz ilyenkor mi
történik amikor hát mikor kirageelünk
vagy valami akkor ja akkor akkor ez így
az izgalom hevébe ott akkor felkiáltasz
és azt mondod hogy most menjünk lőjed í
van hozz azt a snipert nehogy így van
ugyanez értem tehát és alvással nem volt
gondod ilyen szempontból hát nem igazán
most volt egy digitális biztonsággal
kapcsolatos podcastem ami a te epizódod
előtt fog kimenni és az egyik probléma
amit amit most ebbe a generációban
megemlítenek azok az alvászavarok mert a
képernyőnek a az intenzitása meg azok a
fények amit használak tehát hogy hogy
hogy az azok olyan hormonokat kezdenek
el termelni bennünk ami amit ami akkor
termelődik amikor nap fény ér minket
tehát hogy
emiatt éjszaka játszani van egy ilyen
hát hátulütője hogy hogy fáradtan
ébredsz ez ez nem volt jellemző hát egy
néha jelen volt ez
is nem aktívan de azért néha volt mikor
reggel 4y-5 óráig 6:00 óráig játszottunk
akkor és akkor reggel mentél még suliba
á igen volt olyan is és akkor nem
aludtál el órán á nem nem nem nagyon
tanárok tudtak-e bármit is erről hogy te
közben gamelsz
éjszakánként nem igazán vagy nem nagyon
foglalkoztak vele nem nem í radar alatt
akkor
elcsúszott szóval elkezdtél játszani
gondolom az elején már nem azon
gondolkoztál hogy ebből bajnokságokra is
érdemes lenne menni hanem hogy valahol
valahol egy tranzíció volt hol döntötted
el mikor döntötted el hogy ezzel most
komolyabban érdemes foglalkozni hát 2000
20-ba
talán
akkor mentünk először ilyen versenyekre
nem ilyen hivatalos versenyekre hanem
amiket szerveztek a magyarországiak
ilyen mini versenyekre kezdtünk el járni
és akkor döntöttük el hogy minél
komolyabban foglalkozunk ezzel és több
időt szállunk rá ühüm a 7é óránál is
több időt hát
igen volt olyan is és a hétvégen te
mennyit a hétvégen te volt amikor egész
nap játszottunk hm az időtől
időjárástól is függött k tudtunk-e volna
menni vagy nem az egyik kérdés ami
egyből felvetődik bennem az az hogy
ilyenkor ezekkel online kapcsolatokkal
barátok is barátságok is szövődnek
gondolom persze persze sok embert
megismersz és itt amúgy helyileg ki
hányan játszanak vagy vannak-e ilyen
akik komolyabban nyomják így a a
megyénkbe például hát megyébe ilyen
komoly playerek
úgy egy 30 darab van de akit inkább
kiemelnék az van egy szentegyházi bíró
csavika ő egy nagyon jó tdmes játékos
ühüm külföldiekkel is mi az a tdm hát
mikor van egy pálya s 1v1-eznek ühüm van
10 perc ss 40 pontig lehet menni ühüm
ühüm ő is ilyen versenyszinten űzi azt a
nem annyira inkább ilyen külföldiekkel
játszik csak ühüm de ilyen hivatalos
versenyeken nem nagyon és akkor hogyan
kommunikáltok így a játékban hát van a
játékban a mikrofon bekapcsoljuk és
mindenkinek van vagy airpod vagy
fülhallgató fejhallgató tehát amikor
például ilyen négyes squadokba mentek
akkor
egymást halljátok mind pers tát amikor
te megszólal akoror mindenki be van
kapcsolva mindenki hal mindenkit tehát h
gyakorlatilag egy komplex stratégiázás
megy a háttérbe és ha ott van az airpods
a füledben akkor éjszaka felkiált az
hogy mert mert gyakorlatilag kizárod a
külvilágot és és ar igen emlékszem hogy
nehezen tudtalak elérni telefonon nem
kicsit bosszankodtam is emiatt hogy hogy
küldtem egy üzenetet és nem válaszoltál
de utána mondtad hogy valójában
kikapcsolsz ilyenkor mindent minden
notifikációt azért hogy csak a játékra
tudjál figyelni igen viszont egyből
felmerül bennem a kérdés akkor a
külvilágra hogy tudsz figyelni hogyha ha
ott van ez az online világ és ennyire
fókuszáltam benne vagy ebbe a
a hogy hogyan látod hogy hogy egyrészt
vannak-e olyan barátaid akik offline
barátok akikkel húsvét
kapcsolatot hát vannakz és mélyebb
kapcsolat tehát nem egy felületes szia
szia hogy vagyok hanem hanem tudsz
beszélgetni van persze hát inkább itt a
megyébe akikkel szinte nap mint nap
találkozok vagy hetente összeülünk vagy
valami azokkal és hogyan hasonlítanád
össze ezt a mondjam úgy a húsvérbátot az
online baráttal milyen kihívások vannak
itt v hogy hogy hogyan képzeljem el a
kettő között a különbséget hát igazából
sehogy meg mert mind a kettőt vagyis a
külföldieket is már vannak annyira
szoros barátaim külföldiekkel hogy
szinte ugyanúgy veszem őket mint akikkel
minden nap így vagyok csak velük nem
találkozok minden nap de nincs egy
különbség a között hogy húsvéremberrel
találkozol és látod és és és meg tudod
fogni a kezét és el tudtok menni
valamerre meginni valamit vagy yet
sétálni versus az hogy hogy csak
mikrofonon keresztül hallod nem sok
ilyen van
mármint melyik vagyis van egy-két olyan
ember aki akit többnek érzek például
mint a külföldeket de íg nagyjából így
nem teszek különbséget tehát a mondjam
úgy hogy a akkor van egy szűk kisebbség
aki aki a a í van húsvérbarátaid közé
tartozik és a nagy többsége egy ilyen
online ismeri mondjuk ez egy nehéz is
mert valójában hogyha most elkezdesz
barátkozni valakivel leülsz egyet
beszélgetni gyakorlatilag az első öt
mondat után már bizonyos szempontból
szétvált az életetek mert te ebbe vagy
fókuszáltam benne a a slanget ismered a
a pubg-n
belüli kifejezéseket a stratégiákat a ez
a te világod nagyjából akkor hogyan is
tudsz nál kapcsolódni valakihez aki aki
tejesen tik fel magyar irodalmat
szeretne beszélni veled hát én ahhoz is
tudok viszonyulni
igazából én vele is ugyanúgy el tudok
beszélgetni min é miről hát bármiről
szinte bármiről nem bosszand hogy nem
nagyon érti a te világodat egy egy
való világbeli ember nem nem igaza ahhoz
hogy le tudjunk most ülni beszélgetni én
legalább egy órát kellett készüljek hogy
megértsem pontosan hogy tehát azért
tudunk majd beszélgetni mélyen a
pubg-ről mert én készültem de ha most
nem nagyon készültem volna ezért mondjam
úgy hogy azért elég felületes lenne így
a a beszélgetés úgyhogy vágjunk is bele
engem nagyon érdekel így a pubg világa
főleg miután kibontom hogy konkrétan
mire is lyukadtam ki de
kezdjük egy egyszerűbb kérdéssel hogy
szerinted mitől lett ilyen népszerű ez a
pubg játék mert tényleg eszméletlenül
népszerű lett hát szerintem hogy tele
van izgalommal ez a másik pedig hogy
multiplayer mód
van az hogy minden szinte bárkivel
játszható ez a
játék
régióktól
eltekintve mindenkivel külföldiekkel
minden minden mindenkivel mennyire nehéz
megtanulni ezt a játékot hát attól függ
ki hogy áll hozza mert nagyon sok
beállítást meg kell tanulni van aki ezt
a beállítást nem szereti van aki azt van
aki giroszkóppal szeret játszani van aki
giró nélkül ühüm és hát aki jó nekiáll
szeretne megtanulni az egy fél év alatt
deát meg a én most giroszkóp alatt lehet
hogy mást értek te mire gondolsz
giroszkóp alatt tehát hogy arra megy a
karakter meg a viev ja igen igen igen
amerre forgatot tehát gyakorlatilag maga
a kameraállása hogy hogyan igen van te
te hogy és te hogyan játszod én
giroszkóppal játszok te goszkóppal
játszol
igen
nekem elég nehéznek tűnik ez a játék
mármint hogy így ahogy néztem kívülről
nem túl egyszerű elindulni gyakorlatilag
egyből lelőnek hogy ha hát igen ha
kezdőként fogsz neki igen meg meg
gyanítom hogy amiatt is népszerű mert
egy akármilyen telefonnal ele lehet
kezdeni aztán nyilván hogy olyan szintre
vinni aholilyen szinten játszol te oda
oda már egy egy nagyobb teljesítményű
telefon így van igen ha ha most tegyük
fel most valakinek be kéne mutassad ezt
a játékot egy ilyen kezdő valakinek
tegyük fel most odakerülne a szobádba
odaadnánk egy telefon te hogyan kezdenéd
a betanítását annak a személynek mi hogy
hogyan fogjon neki egyáltalán ennek a
játéknak hát először is hogy döntse el
hogy hány újjal szeretne játszani ahhoz
állítson egy olyan kontrollt ami neki
miért hány újjal előt hát ezt akárhány
úra két új is ú is lehet persze van
olyan is így van van olyan is aki 10 új
ját te hány újal játszod én négy újal
játszok a két mutatóújjad vagyis
bocsánat a igen a két mutatójal csak két
nem tudom hüvelykujja é mutatóí zoomolsz
és igen ühüm és e ez ez hogy alakul ki
hogy tehát nekifogsz és és gyakorlatilag
elkezdesz játszani és akkor úgy érzed
hogy melyikek a a azok a kombinációk
amik jobban megfelelnek hát igazából ez
helyzetektől is függ mivel lehet hogy
egyszerre több dolgot is kell csinálni
és oda már nem elég a két huj vagy a
három húj üüm be kell rakni a negyediket
is itt itt ebben a játékban fegyverek
vannak milyen milyen típusú fegyverek
vannak hát vannak sniperek ak smg-k
nagyon-nagyon sokféle van hát akkor
lőfegyverek shotgunok persze igen tehát
ilyen kés meg meg ilyesmi mint a is van
az is de nem nagyon használják vagyis
azt ott adja a játék addig amíg nem
kapod meg az első fegyvert tehát valami
fegyvered van az a az a kés a minimum és
akkor és és mi egyéb van még a
fegyvereken kívül a játékban ami ilyen
ilyen eszköz ként tudod használni hát
van a serpenyű az mi a
serpenyű szó szerint serp azzó és azzal
mit lehet csinálni hát azzal is lehet
ugyanaz mint a kész csak igen igen egy
ilyen viccesebb változata igen és akkor
hogyha serpenyővel őlsz meg valakit
akkor ez egy külön így megjelenik hogy
ez van igen a kill chaten igen igen
azért külön gondolom egy ilyen művészető
hogy lehet serpenyővel őlni hát abból is
vannak fejlesztő serpenyők üüm
mindenféle kill messagees serpenyők
vannak most már neked melyik a kedvenc
fegyvered hát nekem a m416 a az milyen
milyen fegy nem nem ismerem a a tehát
hogy automata í így van abol igen és
miért ez lett a feje miért nem sniper
például hát snipert inkább ipaden ipaden
jó ja mert az az on jobban nagyobb kép
íg van így van igen de és akkor vannak
mobilos sniperesek ugye persze persze
vannak az egy külön művészet megtanulni
akkor hogyan lehet célozni és
igen és akkor vannak
különböző pályák itt itt most hogy
képzeljem el hogy milyen tehát vannak
ilyen hivatalos pályák amik megjegyeznek
és te is tudsz te úgy mint a a a world
of warcraftba vagy vagy a a dotába hogy
vannak saját pályák is amiket tudnak az
játékosok kreálni saját maguknak de
vannak hivatalos pályák itt most hogy
képzeljem el hogy hát csak hivatalos
pályák vannak illetve most már annyi
félét behoztak hogy szinte lehetetlen az
egészen játszani ühüm mindenféle ilyen
öt perces 10 perces két perces s wowóat
meg mindenfélét behoztak eddig csak
klasszik volt illetve tdm ühüm de
ugyanaz a pálya mindig tehát egy
bajnokságon mindig ugyanaz a a nem hát
többféle klasszik mód van hányáó van
most amit hogy versenyeken is játszanak
hát versenyeken úy nagyságrendleg öt 10
50 egy hat- hé pályát szoktak játszani
hat- hét pályát tehát ezek nagyon híres
pályák a gondolom a minden egyes
szegletét ismered hogy mi hol van és hát
nagyjából most már igen minden pályát
ezek ezek nagy pályák tát hog hogy most
már és akkor így randomra dobnak le igen
tehát hogy nem nem tudod hogy hol fog és
amikor amikor tegyük fel duóba mész vagy
pedig squadba akkor egymás mellé dobnak
le titeket vagy pedig az is random hogy
meg kell még kapd a a társad nem hát a
repülőgépből már ketten ugrasz ki ketten
válassztátok ki a helyet ühüm és akkor
egy egy tőernyővel gyakorlatilag nézed
hogy hova igen es le és akkor a serpenyő
ott a kezedbe igen igen hát az egyik meg
kell mondjam hogy akkor kezdtem
belelkesedni hogy kicsit kutassam ezt a
pubg-t jobban
amikor amikor
elkezdtem kutatni a stratégiákat hogy
milyen stratégiákkal lehet játszani és
olyan kísértetiesen hasonlítottak ezek a
stratégiák valamire egy könyvre amit még
évekkel ezelőtt olvastam ez a suncenek a
háború művészete ez egy 2500 éve íródott
könyv amit egy had zér írt sunce és
utána pedig még a a a egy egy későbbi
generációban levő
hadvezér kiegészített de gyakorlatilag
annyira tehát arról szól hogy egy
háborúban milyen alapvető stratégiákat
ez az is a címe a háború művészete hugye
am művészetnek tartja magát a
hadviselést és ezt az 1800-as években
fordították le franciára és angolra
úgyhogy a gyakorlatilag a nyugati világ
akkor ismerte meg de egy annyira
népszerű könyvvé vált való ában egy
füzet a mai standardokhoz mérve és és
annyira népszerű let hogy a menedzsment
és buiznis körökbe egy kötelező műnek
tehát hogyha most valaki a hallgatók
közül beírja a google-be hogy a top 10
vagy lehet a top 50 buizisz könyv a
világon tuti ott van benne a háború
művészete ott van a mi cégünknek a
polcán is én is olvastam és és ez egy
alapmű amit meg kell ismerjenek mert ez
valójában ha egy repetitív helyzetben
vagy az egy olyan mint egy háború egy
olyan mint egy hadviselés ez függetlenül
attól hogy most egy céget próbálsz egy
piacra bevezetni a termékével vagy vagy
egy menedzsment környezetben próbálsz
egy csapatot összeállítani vagy akár
család családapaként
próbálod a a világot megérteni
alapelvekről van szó és olyan
kisértetiesen hang hang hasonlítottak
ezek az alapelvek a pubg-n belül
kialakult alapelvekkel úgyhogy gondol
egy kicsi játékot hozok neked és egy
kicsit kezdjünk el beszélgetni
felolvasok pár idézetet sunc-ől és
kíváncsi vagyok hogy ez rezonál-e veled
hogy valami hasonlót te tapasztaltál-e a
játékban például az egyik stratégia amit
amit ami amit szce ír hogy egy terepen
mindig a magasratról lefele harcolni
előnyösebb mint az alacsonyabb
pozícióból felfele hát ez nem mindig így
van ez nem mindig igaz van mikor ez
pozíció ól függ meg hely helyektől is
ühüm hogy ki hol helyezkedik el például
van a játékban olyan helyek ahonnan
lentről jobb kivárni amíg jön a játékos
másik egy sniper hova érdemes el
rejtőzzön nem nem érvényes az hogy fent
érdemes egy magasati pontó ahol jobban
belátod a környezetedet hát jobb de
esélyesebb hogy lentről inkább kilőnek
ühüm jó tehát akkor ez annyira éppen nem
érvényes a pubg-be mint a mint suncénnél
hát érvényes de nem mindig érvényes de
nem mindig így van hát pozícióktól
helyektől függ igen tehát ezek ilyen
általános alapelvek de kíváncsi vagyok
lássam a többit is például az igazi
harcos türelmes alkalmas pillanatot
kivárja majd lecsap mennyire szükséges a
türelem hát
van mikor nagyon szükséges illetve van
mikor egyáltalán nem kell
ühüm van mikor tehát ha valakinek már
egy squadból három enemit lelovoztál és
tudod hogy azoknak kevés a hp-juk akkor
nem kell megvárni amíg ők heelnek hanem
rájuk kell menni
itt most négy slenget mondtál ebbe a
mondatba szóval volt a hp ez a gondolom
hogy a a a hogy mennyi életereje van és
akkor a egy squadból az tehát
gyakorlatilag azt jelenti hogy négy
személy van egy squadb tehát amikor még
egyszer megismétled ezt a mondatot hát
hogy ha a squadból három enemitt igen az
enemy az az ellenség igen így van ha
lelovozunk az mit jelent hát hogy
levesszük a hp-ját igen egy bizonyos sz
nem haltak meg de márak kés akkor
érdemes már rájuk pussolni pussolni
tehát hogy gyakorlatilag megtámadod őket
igen igen tehát de gyakorlatilag itt az
van hogy kivárod a kellő pillanatot
tehát a türelem az itt itt tehát hogy ha
ha ha nincsenek leloholva akkor vagy
lelohozva vagy hogy hogy hogy mondtad
akkor akkor gyakorlatilag türelmetlenül
mész és ez ez nem egy jó stratégia így
van tehát a taktikai érzés jó menjünk a
harmadikra ismerd az ellenséget és
ismerd magadat és ezer csatában sem
leszel
veszélyben gyakorlatilag itt most pont
ezt mondtad el hogy hogy a ha láttad
hogy abba a squadba a hp-jük le van
csökkenve akkor akkor akkor
gyakorlatilag kiismerted kiismered a és
akkor ilyen szempontból tanulmányozod is
a a egy egy verseny előtt a másik
csapatot persze jó ha ismered hogy kik
ellen játszasz egy-két videót megnézel
velük hogy hogyan játszanak miket
csinálnak persze tehát én ha tudom hogy
látom hogy benne van egy külföldi team
és ismerem is őket akkor tudom hogy
például ez a játékos ez nagyon jó
gránátos folyamatosan mozgásba kell
lenni nem szabad megállni mert ez simán
kigránátoz jó ha ismered a
játékstílusokat ühüm de milyen stílusok
vannak tehát van az egyik a gránátozás
amiről beszéltünk beszéltél most van a
sniper hát van aki jó aerezik illetve
van a cemper igen az mi az aki nem
mozdul nem ad le semmi infót nem trappol
hanem kivárja amíg te odakerülsz azt nem
utálják de igen azt utálják a legjobban
szóval ez emlékszem a counter strike-ból
hogy a akik cempeltek azokat azokat
nagyon-nagyon utálták szóval ez a három
nagyobb kategória a tehát a gránátos a
sniperes és a az ars mind mind a
háromnak különböző stílusa van és és
ezeket kedvelik tehát hogy gyakorlatilag
megvannak a hősei van vannak ilyen
cemperek akik ak mint hősiként
tekintenek ráj ja persze hát vannak
ilyen nagyon nagy külföldi kemperek is
akiknek már több millió illetve több
100ázezer követőjük van ebből lettek
híresek de mi a hogy lehett valaki híres
abból hogy elbújik a játékba is hát ezt
senki se érti ezt senki se érti szóval
nem tudom jó
négyes stratégia a jó hadvezér előnyt
kovácsol a terepből és megnehezíti az
ellenség dolgát tehát gyakorlatilag itt
itt itt arról van szó hogy ismered
egyrészt a térképet és tudod hogy mik az
előnyei bizonyos régióknak zónáknak és
mik a hátrányai és előnyt próbálsz
kovácsolni abból
igyekszel úgy helyezkedni hogy
előnyösebb legyen neked igen hát ez így
van például én ha látom hogy jön a
playzone ühüm ránézek a térképre és
tudom hogy hová fog esni nagyjából akkor
be tudom mérni hogy hová kell menjünk és
melyik házba kell felmenjünk vagy valami
és akkor ilyenkor gyakorlatilag a
squadodnak mondod hogy menjünk a nem
tudom hova mondj egy slenget hogy hova
kell menni ilyenkor hát scholba például
igen tehát ez egy iskola gondolom ami
ami amit elfoglaltok és akkor felmegyünk
akkor mindenki megy és követ téged íg
van
ühüm a siker a készletek kez één múlik
ha nem vigyázol az erőforrásokra gyorsan
elveszíted az előnyt hát ez igaz ez igaz
kifogyhat a lőszered persze persze akkor
gyakorlatilag ez ez abszolút érvényes ha
ha nem akkor maradsz a a serpenyővel
igen hát nem mert meccs közben miután
fegyveret került azt szinte mindenki
kidobja hova dobja ki hát a táskából
kidobja hogy ne foglalja a helyet ja
értem mert lassabban tudsz menni és és
valójában van egy véges kapacitása a
táskád igen
mit tartasz a táskáb hát a fegyvereket a
lőszereket a healeket
hüüm scopeokat ühüm meg a feg ez a scope
ez ilyen ilyen távcső nem így van távcső
meg a fegyvernek kiegészítőket
ühüm amúgy a a a snipernek gondolom az
alapvetően van egy scopeja de az anek is
van scopeja hát az ar-nek azt
legkisebbtől 6x-ig lehet felrakni azt ná
perre már a 8x-et is fel lehet ühüm
ühüm na nézzük a
következőt a háborúban minden a
megtévesztésen
múlik kíváncsi vagyok hogy ez ez
működhet-e a pubg-n felül hogy
megtéveszted az ellen felet hát igen ez
általában sokszor
előfordul honnan tudod hogy a hpl el van
csökkenve egy játék játékosnak tehát ez
ez van egy publikus táblázat vagy
valahol ahol látod vagy amikor rávzed az
egeret akkor látod hát nem hát így van
sejtjük tehát hog ez nem publikus hanem
van egy ilyen sejtés meg lehet
téveszteni a játékos hogy úgy viselkedsz
vagy úgy azt érezteted mintogyha le
lenne csökkenve h ja persze persze és
akkor ezt szoktátok is alkalmazni min
stratégia hogy becsapjátok a még hogyan
csapjátok be a zenelfelet igen hát
sokféleképpen be lehet például hogy ha
igen közel van egy fal vagy két
falválaszt elminket kihúzzuk a gránátot
s az időbe telik amíg eldobod meg minden
addig simán rád tud futni mert nem tudod
olyan gyorsan elrakni van olyan hogy
kihúzzuk é egybe el is rakjuk é akkor
már kijött openre é és ilyenek tá
gyakorlatilag kihúzod a gránátot és úgy
teszel mintha eldobnád és akkor azt
hiszi hogy van egy másodperce így van és
itt az egy másodperc az elég sok idő
gondolom persze az elég sok idő ez egy
ez egy hihetetlenül felgyorsult játék
amúgy azért választottad ezt a telefont
ha jól értettem mer ezt 60 fps-sel is
lehet játszani igen tehát azzal szoktad
60-nal nem hát ezen ami most van ezen
120 van 120al így van és ezt szoktamlni
igen az fps az a fram frames per
secondnek a rövidítése hogy hány
képkockát látsz per másodperc az
átlagfilm az egy ilyen
23 amit a moziban lehet látni az egy
ilyen 23 képkocka per másodperc de a 120
az így azt jelenti hogy nagyon nagyon
nagyon így van hát telefonon eddig ez a
legnagyobb amit be tudtak hozni a 120
érzed a különbséget 120 és 90 között
persze ja hog persze is ráadásul tehát
hog an gördülékenyebb a játék ühüm
eszméletlen ha ha lenne 240 akkor arra
mennél gondolom hát persze arra hát arra
nagyon kíváncsi lennék hogy azt annak
éreznéd a a ki tudja talán kiadnak egy
olyan telefont amelyik a de az iphone
20-as majd egyszer le lehet hogy igen
még nem hát vannak gaming telefonok
azokon nem tudom pontosan de több van
mint 120 több van mint 120 igen hm és
akkor egy ilyen telefont nem akarnál
beszerezni hát nem nem igazán szerintem
nem érdemes tehát már a 120 az elegendő
a h í van az elég igen na menjünk a
következőre összesen 10-et írtam de
szerintem az egész könyvet fel lehetne
olvasni itt a hadvezér ereje nem a saját
képességeiben rejlik hanem abban hogy
képes vezérelni az
embereit vagyis hogyeg squadba most
ahhoz hogy a squad sikeres legyen
mennyire fontos az hogy hogy az
embereket a helyükön tud tartani hogy
jól a a meg megfelő stratégiát
megfelelőképpen
kommunikált és h hogy mindenki a helyén
maradjon ez ez ez mennyire fontos
szerinted hát a versenyeken ez ez
nagyon-nagyon fontos mivel nagyon el
tudnak menni csapatból egy-két ember
több hát 1egy-két méter is számít ha már
távolabb vagytok egymásrra tehát egy egy
fegyelmezetlen csapat
gyakorlatilag gyengébben fog teljesíteni
vagy halálra van ítélve így van persze
ha a csapat nem tart össze tehát nincs
meg az a
hogy annyira össze vagytok szokva nem
vagytok annyira összeszokva akkor
esélytelen az ilyesmi itt mennyire
fontos az alázat szerinted vannak-e
ilyen arrogáns csapatok ahol ilyen belső
konfliktusok vannak és ja persze nagyon
sok van nagyon sok van nagyon sok és
azok nem teljesítenek jól tehát sokszor
lehet gondom amiatt veszítenek el egy
egy meccset mert mert mert arra szánják
az ide például egy más perc hogy a
másikot befiniseljék az mit jelent hát
hogy bedobozolják egész vészen hogy ne
tudd felszedni a
társadat tehát ha lenokkolják akkor ha
odakúszik vagy valami akkor te még fel
tudod szedni és az mit jelent hogy
felszeded hát életet adsz neki és akkor
tud újra healelni ja igen igen de ha
meghalsz a játékb akkor gyakorlatilag
utána már ilyen nézőként nézed hogy mi
történik a mecsben
igen í igen versenyeken igen általános
meccsbe vissza lehet hívni vannak ilyen
lehívók és el kell menni oda tehát azt
azt jelenti hogy és ez mindjárt elmondom
hogy miért nagyon fontos ez a ez az
aspektum ez is felcsillant amikor
legelőször beszélgettünk ez is
felcsillant a
szemen de menjünk végig azen a nyolcas
listán az aki képes változtatni a
tervein és alkalmazkodni az ellenséghez
az lesz a győztes ez ez 100%-osan így
van tehát gyakorlatilag van egy terved
megyünk a scholba és lerohanjunk az
ellenfelet
de de időközben valami másképp alakul
egyből kommunikálsz a csapat fele
alázatosan a csapat megy és alakul
igen például hát ha bemegyünk schoolba
és azt lássuk hogy lent is fent is
vannak akkor esélytelen a dolog akkor
szólok hogy vissza a kocsiba é inkább
elmegyünk valahova máshova ja autóval is
lehet menni persze persze értem az
autóban biztonságosabb egy kicsit a vagy
ott is hát attól függ milyen autó mert
többféle van többféle van azok is így a
pályán el vannak helyezve és annak
függvényében pozicionálósz hogy hol van
egy autó hol tudod be és akkor van-e
üzemanyaga az autónak van az is de azt
táskában nem nagyon tartsuk mivel nagy
helyet foglal ja értem de vannak most
már a pályán behozták benzinkutak és
lehet ott tankolni hihetetlen akkor
akkor folyamatosan fejlődik a játék új
is újabb szabályok jönnek be pers pers
és
ezeket akkor kell kövesd folyamatosan
hogy milyen új szabály jött be ilyen
fórumok vannak ahol hát a frissítéseket
kell követni és az új eventhez
hozzászokni üüm gyakran jönnek ilyen új
hát két havonta ja két havonta
megváltozik egy pic a szabáés így van
kilences stratégia a legnagyobb
győzelmek azok amelyeket harc nélkül
érünk el ezt kábé úgy kell érteni
szerintem ebb a most hogyha ha én kéne
erre válaszoljak hogy néha azt látod
hogy két squad egymást kiszedi csak
türelmesen meg kell várni és igen olyan
is van tehát hogy hogy tudod hogy ha ha
te most beleszólsz akkor akkor magadra
vonod a figyelmed de sokkal élvezetesebb
végignézni ahogy két tehát gyakorlatilag
a politikában is ez történik most a a ha
a nagy hatalmakat nézzük kína
oroszország és amerika is valójában
folyamatosan ebbe
ebbe játszik hogy vajon mikor kell
beleszólni mikor nem kell gyakorlatilag
akkor ez a ez az alapelv érvényes akkor
a pubg-nél is persze igen még még más
jut a eszedbe amikor amikor harc nélkül
érsz el győzelmet hát van az hogyha te
már bent vagy a körben és van még rajtad
kívül egy valaki é az a playzonon kívül
van playon megöli ja igen mer
folyamatosan csökken mennyi idő t hal
meg valaki a playon kívül hát attól függ
hogy mennyire sebez a playon az első kör
nem annyira második még inkább és így
növekszikü egyre egyre így meg sebzőbb
aha úgy néz ki hog a háborúművészete
érvényes ehz a a pubg-re is és az a
meglepő hogy valójában tényleg az van
hogy itt is vannak alapelvek és a sunce
is rájött spontánul azokra az
alapelvekre azáltal háborúzott amire
amire ti is rájöttetek valójában és
ezért érdemes tanulmányozni ezeket a az
alapelveket mert úyanítom hogyha most a
pubg egy idő után nem lesz népszerű
hanem egy másik játék jön akkor ugyanott
ugyanúgy érvényesek lesznek ezek az
alapelvek igen például az egyik ami
engem nagyon megérintett amikor
beszélgettél az az hogy kell figyelj a a
juniorokra akik most csatlakoztak a
játékhoz és kell tanítgasd őket és és és
szeretsz is ezzel foglalkozni valójában
egy jó játékos ahhoz hogy jó legyen
ahhoz le kell hajoljon a kezdőkhöz és
kell segítsen hát igen hát van aki
figyel kívül hagyja teljesen őket
például én is most ha versenyre készülök
és van még két-három órám akkor nyilván
nem azzal foglalkozok hogy valaki bejön
a teambbe és azt mondja hogy
csinálsz-e nekem egy rumot
vagy megmutatod ezt hogy kell beállítani
elmagyaráz akkor nyilván nem tudok
segíteni mert a versenyre fókuszálok de
amikor van időm akkor segítünk ühüm ja
valójában egy foci csapatnál is az ilyen
sztár játékosokat hogyha összerakjuk egy
helyre akkor akik akik csak magukkal
vannak elfoglalva az az nem lehet nem
lesz egy hatékony csapat egy hatékony
csapatban fontos az hogy hogy segítsd és
összejátsz hogy a többiekkel is
lehetőséget hy tudod az a vicces ebbe
hogy a patkányoknál figyelték meg hogy a
patkányok nagyon szociálisak amúgy
egyfolytában egymással birkóznak és ha
egy patkány 10%-kal nagyobb a tömege
mint a a másiknak akkor örökké ő nyer
tehát amikor birkóznak akkor elég 10%
különbség ahhoz hogy mindig a a nagyobb
nyerjen viszont van egy olyan belső ját
szabály is a patkányoknál hogy mindig a
gyengébb hívja ki az erősebbet odamelyik
kicsit táncol akkor elkezdenek egyet
birkózni na de az van hogy ha a nagyobb
játékos nem hagyja nyerni a a kisebb
játékost mármint a kisebb patkányt
30%-ba tehát hogy 10 alkalomból
háromszor nem hagyja nyerni a kisebbet
akkor többet nem fogják elhívni így van
és akkor gyakorlatilag ez amúgy a
csimpánzoknál is érvényes tehát az
alfaahím nem a legdurvább
legbrutálisabb csimpánz hanem egy olyan
személy aki képes kapcsolatot teremteni
a a gyengékkel a nöstényekkel vagy a
gyermekekkel vagy a kis csimpánzokkal
tehát egy ilyen spontán etika kialakul a
csimpánzoknál is és a patkányoknál is de
kialakult a pubgknél pubg kultúrában is
az embereknél is abszolút tehát egy y a
biznisvilágban sem fogsz tudni úgy
működni hatékonyan hogy a a saját
embereidet nem ismered és nem emel ett
fel de a pubg-nél is ez ez spontánul
kialakult ki hát inkább a
magyarországiaknál sajnos magyar
community a a mire írted ezt hogy mi mi
van ott tehát hát nagyon toxikok nagyon
toxikok tehát ha most valaki bejön a
tembe egy magyarországi és mi vagyunk
hárman akkor nem azzal kezdi hogy mi a
helyzet vagy köszönjön vagy valami hanem
egyből kihív hogy gyertek noobok vagytok
és ilyesmi hogy teljesít a magyarországi
csapat világ szerte hát
szerintem
jelenleg nullán vannak nullán hát szó
szerint hát
10-ből 10 versenyből káb kétszer ha
benne vannak a top 10-be ühüm nagyon
gyengék nagyon gyengék gondolod ez az
arrogancia ami ami úgy jellemzi a
magyarországi játékosokat az há igen
mivel vannak jobb játékosok nagyon jó
játékosok is vannak akiket nem visznek
versenyekre tehát
itt is szinte minden a pénz múlik tehát
van egy csapat akik nem annyira jók s
mégis őket viszik tehát az alázat itt is
fontos tehát hogy senki nem akar egy
arogáns valakivel persze persze együtt
játszani de ez ez eszméletlen mert
valójában ha megtanul valaki jól
játszani a pubg-be valójában egyszerre
sok mindent megtanul a világban mert
gyanítom hogy a pincér szakmában is egy
hasonló belső hierarchia kialakul hogyha
egy egy pincér nem tud együtt működni az
összes többi pincér most fő pincér vagy
amúgy ráadásul igen nem tanulsz meg
együttműködni az összes többi pincérre
gyakorlatilag akkor
akkor nem végzed jól a munkádat nem a
feladatod nem az hogy te végezz el
minden munkát a lehető legjobban hanem
hogy az egész csapatot hozzá segítsd
ahhoz hogy hogy sikeres tudjon lenni ez
így a a pincér szakmában hogy látod hogy
ez hogyan vetül le ez a az alapelv
szerintem ez ezzel nincs gond nálunk
egy főpincér mi az amit hogyan tud
figyelni a többi pincére így a kulisszák
mögött milyen ilyen titkokat kell
megsúgjon a többieknek vagy mire kell
figyelmeztesse hát a attól függ én ha
látom hogy egy-két alkalommal jól végz a
dolgát akkor nem nagyon figyelek már rá
ühüm tehát azt látom mert tudom hogy az
ha egy-két alkalommal jól elvégezte
akkor harmadikra is ühüm tehát akkor
megbízhatsz benne hogy az az ember lesz
persze és most van-e valami ami így a a
már most két hete dolgozol ugye a ezen a
helyen már most alkalmazni tudsz így a
pubg-ből így a pincér szakmában tehát
gondolom a a főpincérként van egy csapat
egy hány hány pincérből most jelenleg
ketten vagyunk de duóan nyomjátok igen
de szeretnénk még bővülni ühüm szóval a
a ketten dolgoztok és gyakorlatilag le
kell fedjetek hány asztalt hát egy 25-öt
25 asztalt és gondolom csúcsidőben azért
ez egy kemény feladat igen hogyan tudtok
összedolgozni hát
igazából levondoszva hogy melyik aztal
kihez tartozik gondolom hát nem annyira
nem hát tehát én most a felveszem azt az
asztalt akkor ő felveszi a másikot nincs
megosztva hogy ez az asztal a tiét vagy
ez az övé a lényeg hogy ne nyúljunk
egymás asztalába és akkor nincsen akkor
nem kavarodnak össze a dolgok van és mit
jelent az hogy te főpincér vagy ha
ketten vagytok mi az ami plusz jogod van
a másikhoz képest tehát hogy a báron
belül az árut én rendelem én figyelek
hogyha valami elfogyott meg
ilyesmik kíváncsi vagyok majd hogy ha
négyen lesztek és egy squadba fogjátok
majd nyomni így pincérként akkor
milyen milyen alapelveket fogsz tudni
áthozni a pubg-ből de az az érzésem hogy
ha ha belemennénk ebbe mélyebben akkor
csak tanulnál
stratégiákat hogy hogyan bánj az
emberekkel hogy hogyan segítsd őket hogy
hogyan hogyan vezet győzelemre úgymond a
pincércsapatotokat igen apropó
beszéltünk a pénzről
hogy gyakorlatilag a a jó telefon pénzbe
kerül és
a játékon belül is lehet vásárolni ha
jól értem igen te is szoktál pénzt
költeni akkor erre a játékra szoktam
igen néha nem sokszor de azért szoktam
de össze tudod így számolni hogy mennyi
pénzt költöttél eddige a játékra hát
igazából örülök mert olyan nagyon-nagyon
sokat nem költöttem vele de mégis jó az
akunom hát egy kb
egy 4-500 eurót ühüm
eddig a hét év alatt amíg így van így
van amíg játszottad m az szerintem nem
sok mert van aki egy héten eg- ké millió
miló ftot is belerak a játékba mit lehet
vásárolni a játékban ennyi pénzért hát
skineket igen jönnek be autó skinek meg
minden ezek kerülnek a legdrágábba ezek
miért adnak pénzt ezért a az emberek hát
hogy fejleszték az accountjaikat ja mert
mert ezek az accountok ezek pénzt érnek
persze és hogy a játékon belül is lássák
hogy ők egy szinte mindig cs akkor hogy
van lehet licitálni egy accountra hogy
mennyit ér van persze szokt ilyet is
vannak ilyen különböző
csoportok mik a az általános árak
mennyér lehet egy accountot vásárolni
hát attól függ hogy mik vannak az acc
accountban mennyire régi milyen cuccok
vannak
benne hát
egy egy 400€óér már lehet egy jó
accountot venni amivel a tied mennyit ér
hát jelenleg ami van egy egy 3000 eurót
egy 3000 eurót tehát akkor
nettó profitáb is eddig a a be ja persze
persze és most tegyük fel hogy a
legdrágább accountok mennyibe kerülnek
hát legdrágább nem tudom de egy
nagyon-nagyon jó account több mint
4-5000 euróba is 6-7000 euróba is
kerülhet ühüm hát van olyan ismerősöm
aki 17 millió ftért adta el az ak
accountját 17 millió ft-ért ez és valaki
miért vásárol egy
accountot hát szerintem ekkora okat
vásárolni hülyeség ühüm mert mostanában
mindenféle régi cuccot behoznak ühüm
kicsi pénzért és akkor azt meg lehet
szerezni ühüm tehát gyakorlatilag van
egy ilyen piaci oldala is ennek a
pubg-nek ahol licitálsz és adsz te
szerveszel persze és a másik oldalról
pedig pénzt is lehet nyerni valójában de
ha versenyzel már hát eport szinte
igen amúgy az esportokat most már
hivatalos egy jó pár évvel ismerik mint
rendes sportát bajnokságok vannak és és
komoly
pénzösszegeket lehet nyerni itt
mekkorákat lehet nyerni amúgy hát ez
attól függ hogy mekkora a verseny most
tegyük fel egy országos verseny hát több
mint 4-5000 eur-t is lehet nyerni ezt
4-5000 eur-t a csapat kapja tehát a
squad vagy pedig személyenként annyit
hát attól függ hogy milyen a verseny
hogy van meghirdetve duóban vagy
szólóban van a verseny vagy squadba ühüm
ha squadban van akkor a csapat kapja ha
a csapat kapja a doa is gondolom a
csapat kapja értem és akkor a szólóan is
a csapat mármint egyedül a az a személy
kapja íg jó és eddig te mennyiket
nyertél hát volt olyan országos
bajnokság ahol 45 600 eur-t is ühüm
összesen összeszámoltad hogy eddig
mennyit nyerté nem hát egy egy versenyen
nem úgy értem hogy összeszámoltad az
összes versenyedet eddig hogy mennyit
nyertél nem nem tudom nem tudom
öszeszámolni most így nagyságrendileg
meg kéne saccolni egy 2000 eurónál
többet nyertél igen 5000-nél többet
nyertél á nem azt két le tehát valahol
kettő és öt között lehet van
értem és még az accountot is ér vagy
3000 eurót és most megég megvennié
valaki 3000€óért így van hát ígértek már
érte 4000€ót is de nem adom el mennyi
idő lenne újra kezdeni az egészet
és még egy ilyen 3000 mennyi időnként
tudnál egy 3000 eurós accountot
összeszedni hát
ez a játéktól is függ hogy miket hoznak
be mien en cuccokat milyen időközönként
hát egy egy három évbe belekerülne tehát
három év munkája így van kicsit még
beszélgessünk magáról a a pubg-n belüli
harcról vannak-e ilyen emlékezetes
harcaid amire úgy még most is
visszaemlékszel hogy milyen így van
vannak hát 2018-ban ugye elkezdtük a
játékot é
2020-ban ezt a játékot én a haverom és
két muzsnai egy csaj illetve egy csávó
négyen kezdtük el ezt a játékot velük
vannak a
legemlékezetesebb meccsei ühüm
mindenféle pályán az összesen
ühüm sakkozni tudsz-e nem nem tudsz
sakkozni akkor nem nem tudom megkérdezni
hogy valójában a a sakhoz hogyan
viszonyul mert az is egy egy nagyon
komoly stratégikus játék és akkor
például ha egy ilyen meccset el kéne
vesni kíváncsi vagyok hogy a saját
slengeddel elmesélni mi történt abban a
meccsben amennyire emlékezetes volt
akkor hogyan mesélnéd el hogy akár
belyik mecs amelyikor azt mondod hogy
egy o h még álmodtál is
róla hát ez azért elég hosszú idő lenne
de volt olyan hogy top 50-be oan 10 perc
alatt lehoztuk a meccset tehát hogy
bementünk schoolba felpussoltunk az
egészen és egyszerre négy-öt kadot is
kiirtottunk ühüm tehát azt jelenti hogy
ha van 25 squad akkor hogyha 100-an
indulnak ugye így van és akkor négy-öt
squadot kiirtottatok a hát volt olyan
hogy
összeszámolva a teímem illetve a
csapatom az olyan 70 killt szedtünk
össze az egész mert több mint a mapnak
felét kiirtottuk ez ez mennyire gyakori
amúgy hogy meg meg tudják csinálni tehát
h ez ez gondolom veletek is ritkán
történik meg de mással is hogy hogy
ennyire azért domináljátok a pályát
akkor ez egy ilyen szerencsés szerencsés
játék
volt és így
szólóba szólóba eddig olyan
25 25 és 30 között mármint killk száma
így van a killk száma tehát 100-ból
gyakorlatilag 253 így van ugye az átlag
killid száma mennyi vane így számolva
hát van olyan 810 szokott lenni
általában
810 squadba persze
üüm hát ez a kdn is meglátszik tehát
hogyha bemegyünk rámegyünk valakinek a
profiljára akkor meg tudjuk nézni ha
valakinek van 5,5-ös kd-ja ühüm 100
200sb akkor hát akkor az alapján el
tudjuk dönteni hogy az körülbelül minden
meccsben öt hat enemit ől meg tehát úgy
mint a fociban itt is számolnak
számolnak mindenféle statisztikát meg
pers gyanítom hogy a paretto elv itt is
érvényes a paretto elv ez a 8020-as
szabály nem tudom hallottál-e róla e azt
jelenti hogy most lefordítva a pubg-re
hogy a 20% a osnak annyit öl meg mint az
összes többi 80 tehát hogy egy szűk
kisebbsége annyira sikeres mint az
összes többi 80 és a maradék 20ból is
egy pár tehát hogy most négy annyit öl
meg mint az összes többi 16 és abból egy
annyit mint az összes többi három tehát
hogy
így nincs már tehát ez egy természeti
törvény úgyhogy szinte biztos voltam
benne hogy hogy ezt így követi az
érdekelne hogy szerinted ez a pubg
milyen képességeket
fejleszt a amit amit való életben is
használ tehát hogy beszéltünk már arról
hogy megtanulsz emberekkel együtt
közösen stratégiázni megtanulsz
magas stressz alatt fókuszáltan egy
stratégiát
végigvinni
reflexek most ezek jutnak eszembe még
valami jut-e neked eszedbe ami hát én
amit a legfontosabbnak tartok az a az a
csapatmunka az a csapatmunka az a
csapatmunka én sokkal jobban tudnám
dolgozni egy olyan csapattal akikkel
játszok is tehát hogyha most a pincér
társaidat kiválaszthatnád a a pubg-sek
közül akkor szerinted jobb pincérek
lennétek közösen mint szerintem igen így
van még megosztanátok így a munkaután is
leültök akkor egyet játszani persze lesz
lesznek a gyermekeid igen gondolom igen
hogyan tudod elképzelni hogy naponta
három órát gamelsz és közben gyerekeid
is vannak és én én például nem tudom
elképzelni nekem van három gyermekem és
ez te esélytelen lenne hogy én napi
három órát játszójak szerintem ez ez
megoldható hát sok olyan streamer van
ilyen 30 4050 évesek is akik napi 3om-4
órát 5 órát is streamelnek játszanak de
ebből élnek meg nem nem nem tehát
emellett még van egy civil foglalkozásuk
és emellett még van egy családjuk tegyük
fel pers persze így van és egész jól el
vanannak ezt honnan tudod hát nagyon
sokat beszélünk illetve találkozunk is
tehát hogy egy úgy gondol hogy egy erős
párkapcsolatuk van egy erős házasságuk
így van ez hon tehá miket mondanak hogy
hogy honnan szűrőd le ezt a
következtetés hogy erős a házasságuk hát
feleséges játszik igen ja igen tehát
hogy és hát inkább ez a lényeg igen
hogyha ketten játszanak akkor inkább
megértik egymást hogy miért kell ühüm a
párodat ez alapján fogod majd választani
hogy ő is pubg-zik-e vagy nem nem
igaza mi alapján fogod választani a
párodat hogyha hát még nem tudom addig
még van idő szerintem még még van hogyan
látod hogy így a te
generációdban
a mennyit játszanak az emberek mennyire
gyakori az hogy valaki valaki
számítógépes játékokat játszik vagy
telefonon vagy akárhova nem feltétlenül
pubg-t mert most azt tudjuk hogy van van
egy szűk kisebbség aki játssza akik
nagyon ügyesek van pár 100záz ember
gondolom aki itt a megyében azért
játszik de annyi időt nem fektet bele
milyen más játékokat játsz meg mennyire
gyakori az hogy
hát én más játékokat nem is nagyon
ismerek illetve nem is szeretnék más
játékkal foglalkozni így az osztályban
még játszottak-e más játékokon nem
nagyon nem nem nem igazán cségóztak
egy-két személy és annyi az milyen játék
az a a a chango azt mondtad cg cegoo az
az milyen játék hát én se tudom én is
csak kérdeztem hogy mini játszós akkor
mondta annyiba is hagytam mert nem
tudtam miről van szó
ühüm akkor azt gyanítod hogy a többi a
generációdban a többi fiatal azok
annyira azért nem játszanak számítógépen
hát
a többsége ne többsége ne így van a
többsége miket csinálnak akkor így a a
te generációdbaan a fiatalok mi mi az
amik ilyen népszerűbb dolgok hát
szinte mindenki bulizni jár meg meg
körülbelül ennyi üüm suliba illetve
bulizni üüm a sport mennyire tehát
azokkal akikkel fociztál most ők még
mindig fociznak nem nem igazán hát
szinte akikkel eddig fociztam azok most
már a játékban vannak h melyik játékban
a pubg-be vagy í van a pubg-ba a pubg-be
tehát gyakorlatilag akkor a focicsapat a
covid alatt elvonult egy online világban
így hát így van 95%-a elvonult a
felnőttek szerinted hogyan látják ezt a
a játékos világot mert gyakorlatilag itt
a székelységre ezért nem jellemző ez és
lehet
hogy lehet hogy negatív szemmel néznek
rá te mi miket tapasztaltál eddig hogy
miket milyen visszajelzéseket kaptál
eddig a játékoddal kapcsolatban jót is
meg rosszat is vannak olyan barátaim
akinek a akiknek a szülei nem nagyon
engedik hogy este ez az idő után már
játszodjanak például hangoskodjanak de
van aki engedi
ühüm mert úgy vannak vele tehát ő ha jól
érzi magát abba akkor hadt csinálja és
készüm szerinted h hol lehet
elválasztani hogy valaki függőe a
játéktól
vagy pedig vagy pedig versenyszinten űzi
és emiatt gyakorlatilag olyan mint a
hogyha elmenne futni valaherre vagy hát
szerintem aki a játék
mellett nem tölt szabadidőt valami
mással az az már igen beleírta magát te
mivel töltöd a szabadidődet hát van sok
minden például elmegyünk sízni
hószánozni meg ilyesmik üüm meg nyilván
a munka is most a a így van most már az
a szabadidőd a mka igen hát például
akinek nincsen munkája a fiatalok
többségének és így ennyire beleélik
magukat azok már már azon a szinten
vannak hogy szinte kockák ühüm öt év
múlva akkor te még fogsz játszani
szerintem igen de pincérként is fogsz
dolgozni persze így képzeled el az
életedet hogy mint szakmailag hogy egyik
oldalról pincér vagy teljes munkaidőbe
és utána pedig
játszol és akkor még idejön a család és
a a gyerekek és ez ez remélet hogy
fenntartható lesz persze azt el tudod-e
képzelni hogy játékból megélj hogy olyan
szinten játszolj majd hogy hogy ez egy
stabil bevételt jelentsen majd neked hát
azt is megtudnám oldani van van van
valaki aki akit ismersz hogy eből élj
meg van persze sok mindenkit itt a
környékről is vannak
olyanok de én ezt nem szeretném nem
szeretnék egy online világba hüüm lenni
egész végig miért nem hát nem szeretnék
úgy az online-ból megérni hüüm szeretem
a fizikai én legyen egy fizikai
vonatkozása is az életednek mennyit
lehet keresni ezzel most így euróbaan
hogyha most tegyük fel azt mondanád ezt
az utat választanád online világba
mennié de nem most nem akarod de tegyük
fel ezt választanád akkor mire
számíthatnál mekkora fizetést tudnál
ebből kihozni hát ha én ezt kéne
csináljom akkor napi 10 órát
csinálhatnád ezt hát akkor minél több
versenyre onnan lehet tö így van onnan
lehet a legtöbbet hát napi néy-öt
versenyből is akár több mint 1500 2000
eurt is lehet tehát napi 2000 eurót 1500
eurót így van hát stabilan ha ilyen
kisebb versenyekre jelentkezel és érzed
hogy te azt hot simán meg tudod nyerni
és arra kicsit rákészülsz nyilván ott
nem olyan nagyok a tétek hanem 2-300
eur-s akkor napi ö-h ilyen versenyre is
el lehet menni mert nagyon sok verseny
van tehát még még meg akarom ezt
ismételni mert ez a felnőtt füllel ez
egy nagyon furcsa mat tekett eredményez
gyakorlatilag hogyha most próbáljuk meg
egy kicsit konzervatívabban meg tegyük
fel 1000€ót naponta meg tudnál keresni
ezzel
hát igen na 500 eur igen de arra azért
rá kell készülniá kell készülni t f az
életedet erre szánnád 1000 eur-t naponta
megtudnál ezzel azt jelenti hogyha most
éppen szabadnapokat is kiveszed meg
minden hétvégén nem dolgozol akkor
havonta 20000 eurót összeetudnál ezzel
hát össze lehetne igen össze lehetne de
arra nagyon-nagyon fel kell készülni
azért
azt nem tudom hogy tudod-e hogy 20000
eurót nem keres egy egy programozó sem
és hát igen ezzel a játékkal elég sokat
lehet keresni de hátrányai is vannak
milyen hátrányai vannak hát például nem
lehet azért egy játékba élni így egész
végig hogyha valaki ebből szeretne
megélni az egy dolog de
a én nem tartom jónak hogy csak a
játékból megélni hát meg ott van
gyakorlatilag amúgy ezt legálisan lehet
cs csinálni tehát hogy létrehozol egy
céget bejegyzed és akkor akkor adót
fizetsz a játék után vagy valakit így
ismersz vagy ez teljesen illegálisan
megy hát
ilyent nem igazán nem igazán ismerek
tehát akkor ez gyakorlatilag valahol
bitcoinba valahol kiveszed vagy
valamilyen formába online ott elköltöd
de tehát nyilván már 20000 eurót nem
lehet csak úgy ha mondta
illegálisan mozgatni gondolom arra már
kéne valami jogi hát keretet hát igen
valami ilyesmi
hm e ez ez ez számomra annyira
hihetetlen ez tényleg így lehet hogy
valaki lehet persze hát van van egy-két
külföldi ilyen ismerősöm akik egy 25-30
évesek csak versenyekre járnak te most
hogyha beszorzom tegyük fel egy év alatt
valaki 240000 eur-t keresne most nyilván
nem így működik de hogy csak a matek
kedvéért egy
nagyon jó programozó amerikába bruttóba
keres egy olyan 150000 eurót körülbelül
gyakorlatilag amerikában itt itt
romániában most nem tudom hogy 60000
euró körül lehet tényleg lehetséges
lenne hogy valaki
játékból ennyi pénzt összeszedjen hát
lehetséges ebből a játékból lehetséges
de nagyon kevesen vannak akik erre
rászánják az egész idejüket meg gyanítom
hogy tehetség kérdése is tehát hogy nem
az van hogy pers persze hát van nyilván
van ezt nem tudja soha elérni mert nem
tud feljutni arra a szintre hüüm de
vannak akik akik meg tudnák csinálni és
nem akarják de vannak akik csinálják is
üüm lehet-e amúgy csalni ebbe a játékba
lehet persze hát nagyon sok hacker van
az az mit csinál a hacker hogyan tud hát
különböző programokat telepít vpn-t meg
ilyesmit akkor előnyösebb neki a
játéküüm de ezt kiszűri a játék ühüm
legtöbbször legtöbbször tehát a vpn-en a
tehát hogy gyakorlat pc-n vagy vagy
tabletten játsz de valójában úgy tűnik
minth ha mobilon játszanál gondolom ez
az egyik fajta csalás igen és a a
célzásban lehet-e valahogy segíteni
tehát ilyen reflexeket hog lehet persze
hát van olyan programok is vannak hogy
bescóolz akkor nem muszáj neked
beállítás hanem csak úgy álloszkóp ja
egyből az ellenség í üüm ezt is ki lehet
szűrni ki persze tehát hát mi valahol
úgy érezzük hogy ez a ez a csapat csalt
hogy valami nem stimmeltet velük akkor
bereportoljuk é a játék majd leellenőrzi
most minden az ai körül forog
gyakorlatilag érződik az hogy a levegő
így vibrál és és nagyon izgatottan várom
én is hogy lássam merre fog haladni az
ai
világa te hogy látod hogy a mesterséges
intelligencia hogyan jelenhet meg ebbe a
játékba vagy már megjelenik-e valamilyen
szempontból hát
meg megjelenik tehát a botokat is is már
azt teszi be de ezekre szükség is van
mert ezek javítják szerintem a játékot
például a kezdők számára ühüm mennyire
erősek a botok hát vannak akik erősebbek
gyengébbek tehát hogy akár te is
gyakorolhatsz botokkal annyira ügyesek a
botok hogy már tudsz fejlődni velük hát
nem hát egy meccsbe például a versenyen
nincsenek botok mt 100 enemi van ühüm de
elindítunk egy sima meccset abból kábé
10 enemi az bot és hogy látod hogy egy
bot értelmesen tud jobb stratégiát mint
egy egy egy ember vagy az ember mindig
jobb lesz mint a bot kivéve ha csal mert
a counter strike-ban ez volt hogy
egyfolytában csaltak a botok hát
szerintem
jobbak lesznek még egy kezdő is jobb
lesz mivel a botok azok általában állnak
egy helybe jaj ühüm és
nagyon ritkán
mozognak hogy látod a jövőt ilyen
szempontból a pubg merre fog
fejlődni hát szerintem minél jobban fog
fejlődni milyen fejlődési területeket
látsz vagy lehetőségeket gondolom a
pályák fognak fejlődni újabb szabályokat
hoznak be hát szabályokat nem is de
pályákat minél többet be fognak hozni az
is lehet hogy a frissítéseket havonta
fogják nem kéthonta ez is megtörténhet
üüm hát volt már olyan is hogy behoztak
egy rossz eventet az nem tetszett
senkinek és akkor mindenki posztolt nem
akartak játsz így van és lecserélték az
miért volt rossz nem tudom én akkor
voltam ilyen kihagyásos hüüm időszakba e
ez mi miért volt egy ilyen időszakot hát
akkor tanultam nagyon rá voltam állva a
joksira üüm és ekkor kihagytam két-három
hetet ühüm az érettségivel volt-e
probléma
nem volt érettségi szakvizsga volt
szakvizsga volt a szakvizsgával hogy
tudtál felkészülni volt-e vele kihívás
nem volt nem volt nehéz megkérdezem
hányast kaptál
98 pontot kaptam 100-ból 98 pontot igen
az hp-nak is sok hát igen na hát le a
kalappal
így végezetül azt kérdezném meg
hogy mit üzennél
egy hasonló fiatal most ti a az az alfa
generáció aki előtted van és most
tizenpár éves mit üzenni nekik hogyha
gondolkoznak azon hogy neki fognának
valamilyen online játékot játszani
bátorítanád- őket hogy ássák bele
magukat valamilyen játékba hát a vagy
inkább ónád őket hát
szerintem a pubg-baan mindenkinek
érdemes a pubg-nak a pubg- van
mindenkinek ér mitől óvnád őket mi a mik
a veszélyei a pubg-nek hát hogy nagyon
hát az elején
hogyha nem figyelnek oda akkor nagyon
könnyen elkapja őket a játék illetve
több 10-1 órát is is ühüm el tud venni a
játék tőlük van olyan ismerősöd
amelyiket elkapott a játék é te te is
azt mondod hogy ez ez már kicsit sok van
van persze és az hogyan jelenik meg az
életében hát van olyan is hogy
megbeszéltük hogy elmegyünk egy órát
szünetelni vagy valami 10 perc már
visszaléptem és látom éogn még máig fent
van é még máig játszik ühüm cs ak hogy
mi történik ezekkel a fiatalokkal
bezárkóznak és az életük erről kell
szólni hát van ilyen is de hál istennek
az én csapatom az én baráti köröm nem
nem ilyen hanem megbeszéljük hogy most
ekkor játszunk és akkor neki állunk és
játszunk keményen ha most tegyük fel a
csapatodba egy ilyen játékfüggő
felbukna engednéd hogy játszodjon vagy
inkább azt mondanád hogy ez ez a te
életedre ez már nem nem nincs jó
hatással hát nem igazán engedném illetve
ami most van barátköröm a csapat azt nem
is nagyon cserélném le ühüm nem
cserélném le hát akikkel elkezdtem hány
évesek hát
2021 és nekik is van akkor munkahelyük
valami mellett van persze persze mivel
foglalkoznak hát egyik asztalos a másik
a csaj az
műkörmökkel foglalkozik és a másik
autókereskedéssel és gyakorlatilag 18
éves koruk után már elkezdtek dolgozni
ezek a személyek persze és emellett a
akkor még játszanak ők is ilyen
két-három órát naponta együtt persze
igen hát együtt hát
most hárman játszunk egy jó ideje mert
két éve egyik tagunk a csaj az nem
igazán játszik hm mert nagyon sok időt
szán a munkájára ühüm üüm és ezért
kicsit kihagyja a játékot de szeretnék
ezt a csapatot újra visszakapni üüm úgy
folytatni ahogy elkezdtük hüüm ezt
lehetségesnek látod hogy valaki
gyermeket szüljön és mellette még
játszódjon van erre példa van persze
hogy hogy egy családos anyuka játszik
például igen hát van magyarországra
egy-két ilyen ismerősünk is hm hát most
már magyarországiakkal nem igazán
játszunk
egy-két
toppos lányjátékos van akikkel szoktunk
játszani ühüm egyik ebből a klánból van
ahol vagyok én és van egy másik kata
rainbow gaming úgy van tiktokon fön
ezzel a kettővel
23-val mit üzennél azoknak a szülőknek
akik így most ezt meghallgatják és azon
arra gondolnak hogy szunce ide szunce
oda stratégia de akkor is félek hogy a
gyermekem rá fog szokni erre a a
pubg-re mivel tudnád megnyugtatni ezeket
a
szülőket hát hogyha ráfigyelnek hogy egy
bizonyos időszakot ne lépjenek túl ne
vigyék túlzásba és azt látják hogy ebbe
ők jól érzü magukat akkor szerintem
ühüm és ez nekik kikapcsolódás akkor
szerintem hadd
csinálják valamiről még beszélnéle
mielőtt lezárjuk ezt a az epizódot hát
a gaming
kapcsolatok ról vagy a sima
kapcsolatokról hogy hogyan viszonyulnak
egymáshoz például azt látom hogy akik
nem játszanak a játékkal
fiatalok azok például az én korosztályom
nagyon könnyen eldobnak mindent
erkölcsket mindent tehát már nincsenek
igazi nem nem látom azt hogy legyenek
igazi barátságok például a legtöbb ilyen
hogy szia hogy vagy sehogy ne jó akkor
szia és a hátuk mögött persze elhordják
egymást mindennek én a legtöbbsző ezt
látom főleg itt a környékünkön ezt látom
például
franciaországban egy rendőr megölt egy
fiút nem olyan régiben és a fiúnak a
barátai felgyújtották a város egy részét
a mi barátaink pedig rámennek az exinkre
rámennek a mire az
exeinkre tehát hol vagyunk akkor ilyen
téren sehol de van egy gaming
kapcsolatok tehát most ha találkozik két
olyan személy aki játszik a játékkal az
sokkal jobban viszonyul egymáshoz mint
hogy akik nem játszanak üüm egyből le
tudnak állni két- háom ö percet is
beszélgetni fél órát is üüm bármiről
tehát azt látod hogy van egy
megtartóereje ennek a játéknak van
persze tehát a aki a játékon kívül
inkább káoszt látsz és hogy hogy
céltalanul bolyonganak a a fiatalok igen
és és amiatt mert van egy belső
etikai struktúrája ennek a játéknak egy
belső fegyelemmel kell
alázattal bőségmentalitással viszonyulj
a többiekhez fel kell emeld a
gyengéket stratégiákat kell közösen
kivitelezzetek ez gyakorlatilag mind egy
olyan habá ár online világ mégis egy
mindegy olyan olyan
belső hangulatot és és struktúrát alakít
ki ami gyakorlatilag megtart titeket
persze hát ez a játék ez számunkra most
már teljesen a kikapcsolódásról szól
tehát ez annyira összetart minket hogy
szerintem semmi más nem képes ez egy
nagyon érdekes gondolat volt köszönöm
szépen azt hiszem hogy befejezésnek ez
így pont jó attila köszönöm szépen hogy
eljöttél én is köszönöm szépen és sok
sikert akkor neked a a következő öt
évben mint főpincér kíváncsi vagyok az
első squadoddal majd hogyan fogsz
boldogulni esetleg majd írj egy üzenetet
jó
és szép napot neked köszönöm szépen ha
tetszett ez a műsor akkor iratkozz fel
kérlek a csatornánkra ezzel tudsz
támogatni minket köszönjük a vekker
kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatásért nékületek
nem jöhetett volna ez létre